let's continue on with this thread here
the number 17 uh tweet from Barry Weiss
gets really really interesting because
now you start to see that Twitter was
lying about their bias check this out
Mary y says the account lives of tick
tock which Chaya reichick began in
November 2020 and now boasts over 1.4
million followers was subjected to six
suspensions in 2022 Alone rychic says
each time she was blocked from posting
for as long as a week Twitter repeatedly
informed rychik that she had been
suspended for violating Twitter's policy
against hateful conduct
but in an internal s-i-p PES Memo from
October 2022 after her seventh
suspension the committee acknowledged
quote Libs of tick tock has not directly
engaged in behavior violative of the
hateful conduct policy they were lying
that's actionable
shocker I think that's legal action
right there I think this is um right
here actual malice Libs of tick tock uh
Chaya lawsuit time if they publicly
stated you violated the kind of hateful
uh their hateful conduct policy but then
internally said you didn't that means
they knew they were lying but here's
here's here's the thing does she Sue
Elon Musk now yeah Scott you mentioned
that before the show too what's the
process of uh of a lawsuit in this
situation do you go after a previous
ownership
I would think so I mean
you would have to who was the decision
maker was it Vijaya I I would go after
the individual person as opposed to
Twitter the company because clearly all
of this was done before the Elon Musk
Administration well there's names being
named here a part of their strategic
response team and the group's name and
who was heading them and it looks like
Vijaya was at the head of many of these
important decisions uh we go back in the
in the tweets and you know the the
documents are here it shows us exactly
who is making these decisions why they
were making them how they were making
them up and how a lot of this was just
absolutely arbitrary especially when it
came to hypocritical moves especially
when it came to Libs of tick tock being
doxxed the the the doxing of lips of
tick tock garnered what was it I think
Barry White says 10 000 likes and that
wasn't stopped but but her doing
something that they construed on the
technicality was which wasn't even uh
you know correct which they knew
1000 likes on this doxing tweet and they
said no it's fine I had someone uh post
an insane thread with an address and
Twitter told me they would not take it
down
and I was like okay whatever
then it leads to exactly what you'd
expect to lead to they claimed their
justification for removing uh Libs of
tick tock and the suspension was
indirectly violating their policies by
tweets that delete that either intend to
Insight or LED people to then harass
so not inciting not harassing but
because she posted video and someone
else did well that's indirect so we're
gonna suspend her even though it doesn't
violate our policies however you post an
address and sorry nothing in an internal
slack message Twitter employees spoke of
using technicalities to restrict the
visibility of tweets and subjects here's
Joel Roth Twitter's then head Global
head then Global head of trust and
safety in a direct message to a
colleague in 2021
he wrote A lot of times S.I has used
technicality spam enforcement as a way
to solve a problem created by a safety
under enforcing their policies
which again isn't a problem per se but
it keeps us from addressing the root
cause of the issue which is that our
safety policies need some attention
amazing six days later in a direct
message with an employee
Roth requested more research to support
expanding quote non-removal policy
interventions like disabling engagements
and de-amplification slash visibility
filtering
Roth wrote the hypothesis underlying
much of what we've implemented is that
if exposure to misinformation directly
causes harm we should use
remediations that reduce exposure and
limiting the spread and virality of the
content is a good way to do that in
other words these people are saying
your ideas lead to things that we don't
like regardless of what that may be we
are going to stop people from being able
to see what you post
and then they had the the audacity to go
publicly and say we don't chat about
conservatives
now here's a funny thing the whole time
they were doing this I was saying it's a
semantic game they'll say we we don't
Shadow ban anybody it's called
visibility filtering it's totally
different they would say we did not
Shadow ban anyone for being conservative
we Shadow ban them for misgendering
someone of course liberals and
conservatives have you know opposing
views on what misgendering is so of
course they're literally doing it based
on the political ideology or political
values of the individual yeah I didn't
punch you in the face I just threw my
fist at your your uh you know face you
know so that's technically not the same
thing right guys it's absolutely
incredulous it's absolutely like insane
Congress says uh you know Miss God a is
there a door on the front of Twitter's
building no there isn't there's no door
uh no there's not what do you mean
there's not well what we have is a large
pane of Glass on hinges with a handle
that when you pull it actually moves on
the hinge creating an opening for which
you can move through but it's not a door
okay what
it's the deconstruction of language man
that's the game they play and all
ethically the idea that bad information
how did they phrase it how did this guy
yell phrase this the bad information get
into the other oh I don't know what you
said but he basically was insinuating
that getting misinformation will make
people evil or whatever so show them
less information but I think that's like
it's like saying that
if a virus makes you sick don't don't
expose anyone to the virus but we know
that immune system is a real thing and
you need a little bit of exposure to
enhance your immune system so that you
can handle it when it inevitably comes
around misinformation will inevitably
come around you need to be resistant to
it you need to understand it and be able
to spot it and question information when
you see it but just making it so people
don't ever get a chance to be exposed to
it is not the way to make people
stronger that's my that's my belief on
ethics on this one you know one of the
craziest things I love I love the amount
of weird Flack we're getting from all
these Lefty organizations about the yay
stuff
someone super chatted because I don't
know I may have missed it that yay said
to Alex Jones
maybe I shouldn't have singled out an
entire group of people and just pointed
out at the banks something like that
someone commented that I don't know if
he actually said that but uh if that is
the case it shows you how these
conversations actually do good it shows
how on Twitter there's that famous story
of the Westboro Baptist Church woman who
got de-radicalized by being on Twitter
and saying these things and then people
countering and then eventually she was
like okay maybe I'm wrong
I I feel like what what they really want
they want villains you guys have you
seen that what's that what's that group
of Feds that marches around pretending
to be conservative activists oh yeah are
they feds
do we know that I think they glow you
think they glow so anyway look everybody
sees that group and they're like that's
not it can't be real right
they need villains they need something
to justify their their their laws that's
why they want people to get violent
don't get violent it's the one thing
they know how to how to respond to so if
they can't get it they fake it the FBI
gets a bunch gets like what 12 FBI
agents get two crack pots and then keep
elbowing them being like come on kidnap
this lady and they're like uh gas aha we
got you and then they have this big mock
trial and then try to lock these guys up
they need villains but it's essentially
what the CIA has been doing with
American foreign policy for the last few
decades all going all the way back to
the mullahajin in Afghanistan that
became the Taliban going back to of
course uh the rebels in north of uh Iraq
that became Isis and in Syria that of
course were there against the regime
because we needed regime change and I
could keep going on and on and on but
there's there's a long history of
setting up your opposition in order to
uh give yourself an excuse to have
um you know strict uh tougher more um
brutal force down the Patriot Act is
another example of it but but these
these tweets are still coming in right
now Blair white just tweeted the Jack
Redemption Arc is over after of course
we're finding out through these uh
disclosures that Jack Dorsey was on
board uh with implementing this for
quote Civic Integrity this is not Civic
Integrity this is the destruction of of
dialogue of conversation of people being
able to honestly have conversations with
each other and they stood in the middle
of that and said no we're going to
control what goes into your mind we're
going to control what you can say and
cannot say we're going to control who
gets to see these large ideas the best
idea won't win my idea will win and
that's just disgusting patronizing
messed up behavior of of you know Big
Brother uh Big Daddy government
controlling every aspect of your life
and that's exactly what these people I'm
just going to let everybody in on some
Insider information
um it's nothing crazy uh but I've I've
frequently hit up Jack and asked him to
come on the show he's a year ago he said
yes when when he had time it's been a
year so I hit him up again I'm like you
know it's about that time it's the
annual ask Jack to come and have a
conversation and I understand by like
coming out and saying this and being
critical of them the likelihood that he
actually wants to come on is low but
what I think of Jack Dorsey is that he
built a sewer and then he crawled to the
lowest point of the piping placed his
mouth firmly on the spigot and turned it
on and just let it all flow into his
body what I mean by that is in the early
days of Twitter this was a tech bro he
was like a Libertarian style Tech bro he
was the Free Speech wing of the Free
Speech party he created the platform
that just started loading up with refuse
from woke activists spouting garbled
nonsense and then he started consuming
that garbled nonsense and buying into it
and believing it and then he ended up
because the the machine was going right
down his throat vomiting all that stuff
back out into the platform so when you
have a bunch of activists demanding
censorship arguing this is the right
thing to do and you give it a little bit
eventually the only thing you see is
their arguments and then you start
buying into their arguments then as the
person controlling the system you start
implementing rules based on their
arguments so from Free Speech wing of
the Free Speech party to gargling on the
refuse of voc activists and spitting it
back in their faces and everyone else's
I wonder if what he said it was his
civic responsibility or for the Civic
righteousness or whatever he said why he
was Banning and Shadow Banning I wonder
if it's because the government was like
you know it's your civic responsibility
they're there with handcuffs like dudes
what it's your civic responsibility
better do it like wink wink we're gonna
throw in prison if you don't and that's
why he's talking about decentralizing it
and creating a protocol instead of a
centralized Network because if you have
a centralized Network DEA wants to or
not the DEA whoever government agencies
are going to want to control it they're
going to try and protect it they'll call
it but I mean they want to get in there
and choose what people see and you know
what people are told Dave Rubin just
retreated his conversation that he had
with Jack Dorsey in 2020 where Jack
specifically told him that there's no
Shadow Banning based on political
beliefs I just retweeted it myself uh at
look we are changed on there on Twitter
uh but again 20 20 Dave Rubin
specifically was asking hey are you guys
Shadow Banning yes or no Jack Dorsey
responded and said no they're justifying
double speak by saying it's not a band
or anything another algorithm intake or
your app flow it's not it's ridiculous
there's some Nuance of the Tweet we have
to address Dave Rubin said do you Shadow
ban based on political beliefs simple
yes or no will do and Jack said no and
this is the problem
they're using semantics to lie no it's
nothing to do with their political
beliefs you can vote for Republicans but
if you want lower taxes smaller
government believe it that there's only
two genders well then we'll ban you but
that's politics no no no no see politics
refers to who you vote for
right
those are the games they play yeah you
can ask any question and they will find
some legalese nonsensical semantic
argument as to why they're they're doing
or not doing the whatever they're
supposed to be doing or not doing well I
mean people question elections that gets
banned online I've heard and that's
total politics so obviously if you're
involved in suppressing people
questioning elections around the world
then you're involved in political
suppression get that straight well I
asked Elon when I was on the space with
him and I said
have advertisers threaten to pull money
if you didn't adhere to a certain policy
or have lawmakers threaten to introduce
legislation should you not adhere and I
wonder if that's been going on as well
you know the threatening of introducing
policy or legislation that would hurt
Twitter's ability if they didn't censor
people you know because Twitter came uh
came along when President Obama was in
office right it wasn't just under
pressure yeah I think so 2008 maybe and
so maybe he was getting some of those
pressures from democratic control
but I I think you're right Tim it's not
necessary they do need a villain but to
expand upon it more
when we aren't the villains that they
say we are they have to create that and
then point the finger and say see see
exactly what I was talking about and
then they can use that as an opportunity
for censorship
Etc did you guys see Malcolm flex's
tweet about yay it was brilliant he was
like Yay went on with Tim pool Alex
Jones and gav McGinnis these people that
the left keeps claiming are Nazis and
none of them would agree with him on the
Jews must like it must have been very
frustrating for you talking about dude
yeah exposed Alex Jones for being
awesome that was a picture of Yale being
sitting there looking all frustrated
right right yeah I ever tweeted that one
it was the Bernie Sanders meme where
he's sitting there like but they put
yay's face mask over it and his jacket
and the idea is basically like I wonder
if that was the case you know if you're
yeah and you're not super into politics
this way like you may have some
ancillary view of it but the activists
keep saying like oh Alex Jones is a
fascist he's a Nazi and then you're like
okay so you go and hang out with them
and Alex is like no I hate all those
people I want nothing to do with it
you're like wait what
everybody told me that was the case so
this is the funny thing even Gavin
McGinnis who they claim is the far-right
white supremacist Neo-Nazi proud boys
he's telling yay to stop judging people
based on being a part of a group and a
judge him like individuals and I wonder
if what yay actually did was just
grabbing the Overton window and ripping
it as far to the right as he possibly
could
I think so he I mean he really made Alex
look like a good guy that interview made
Alex look like the defender of
righteousness man because yay was
throwing some nonsense at him and he
knew he was and Alex was just like I got
I gotta stop you there man well they're
they're one Bridge Too Far they're
desperately trying so uh there's an
article that came out it's from I think
maybe the independent or something or
Yahoo and it was like Tim Poole profited
off of yay's anti-Semitism or something
like that and then it was like because
he came on the show and said this stuff
and then I disagreed with him and we
made super chats they're arguing that it
was profiting off of hate or whatever
and I'm like or is it profiting off of
opposing hate they're just going to keep
lying they're going to keep trying to
manufacture some kind of narrative to
create Boogeyman and villains
because the only thing they have it's a
cult it's very disturbing that people
think we could create a world where
people aren't mean or cruel like that is
complete impossibility and Insanity to
think that we could suppress the human
will so much that people will just be
nice all the time thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time